Boa noite a todos é um prazer estar
novamente com vocês nessa Live para a
nossa comunidade aberta fico muito feliz
de poder falar de um assunto muito
importante com vocês e poder estar
respondendo também as dúvidas ao vivo de
vocês temos já algumas perguntas aqui
nós vamos responder Depois aí da
exposição Inicial então cumprimento a
todos boa noite que vocês tem uma
excelente noite uma excelente final de
semana aí a partir da sexta-feira a
partir de
amanhã então esta noite Vamos embarcar
uma viagem pela mente explorando as
complexidades da memória Os desafios da
demência e mais importante as medidas
proativas que podemos tomar preservar a
nossa saúde cognitiva para prevenção
para que a gente não tenha essa doença
tão impactante n nossas vidas essa Live
foi um pedido de um seguidor nas
postagens da comunidade do YouTube então
se você quiser mais lives com temas do
seu interesse não deixe de acompanhar as
postagens da comunidade do YouTube aba
de comunidade do YouTube então fiquem
atentos a isso bem à medida que
envelhecemos as nossas faculdades
mentais muitas vezes entam em foco e com
a demência tornarse uma preocupação cada
vez maior cada vez
mais crescente para muitos devido à
situações que aconteceram nos últimos
anos que nós não vamos entrar em
detalhes mas que vocês sabem que houve
um aumento aí de complicações
especialmente tromboses e isso vai
impactar muito a questão da Saúde
cognitiva nos próximos anos vai aumentar
muitos casos de demência não precisamos
entrar em detalhes vocês sabem do que eu
tô falando então é crucial que abordemos
essas questões de frente para prevenir e
tratar o mais rápido possível qualquer
queda de
cognição então perda de memória e
demência são termos que podem invocar
preocupação e uma infinidade de questões
e o que que causa essas
condições isso nós vamos abordar nessa
Live será que pode ser evitado ou
podemos retardar a
progressão isso é um fato nós vamos
falar sobre isso então examinaremos as
pesquisas mais recentes
desmascaramos desmascaramos Desculpa tô
falando errado essa palavra
desmascarar mitos e forneceremos
estratégias baseadas em evidências para
dar suporte à saúde e funcionamento do
cérebro então ao longo da nossa
discussão nós vamos nos basear nos
insights de especialistas Como é o Dr de
braden que foi Pioneiro em uma abordagem
abrangente pro aprimoramento cognitivo e
a prevenção da demência e eu fiz a
formação dele Anos Atrás a formação um e
a formação dois e acredito firmemente
que essas medidas que nós vamos
conversar hoje elas previnem e tratam a
demência num quadro Inicial ou até mesmo
moderado se você conseguir fazer o
programa de uma maneira abrangente que
muitas as pessoas têm dificuldade Então
examinaremos como os nossos hábitos
diários desde os alimentos que comemos
até a qualidade do nosso sono podem
desempenhar um papel na nossa
longevidade cognitiva ao final dessa
transmissão você que está assistindo
estará equipado com uma compreensão mais
profunda de como nutrir o seu cérebro de
fortalecê-lo contra os desafios que
acompanham o processo de envelhecimento
então Fique atento acompanhe até o final
esteja confortável Pegue uma água para
você alguma coisa para você acompanhar
essa Live de uma maneira bastante atenta
pegue também os seus blocos de nota
vamos mergulhar juntos no mundo da Saúde
cognitiva é importante você anotar os
pontos principais que nós vamos
conversar aqui porque quando você
escreve você ative várias regiões do seu
cérebro e isso aumenta ou a compreensão
e aumenta a apreensão do
conhecimento Então vamos começar
entendendo o que que é a perda de
memória que pode levar a déficit
cognitivo e posteriormente a demência
Então à medida que nós aprofundamos na
nossa exploração da Saúde cognitiva é
essencial compreender os conceitos de
perda de memória e demência então a
perda de memória que é uma ocorrência
comum à medida que nós vamos
envelhecendo pode se manifestar de
várias formas desde você esquecer uma
chave até um esquecimento mais
significativo que pode interferir de
maneira impactante na sua vida cotidiana
então é importante reconhecer que lapso
de memória ocasionais não
necessariamente indicam que a pessoa vai
desenvolver uma demência esse termo
demência abrange
uma série de condições médicas então
muitas vezes as pessoas pensam que
demência é sinônimo de Alzheimer porque
ficou muito impactado essa palavra a
doença de alzheimer só que existe vários
tipos de demência o Alzheimer responde
por 70 a 75% dos casos Ou seja é
realmente a causa mais comum mas tem
vários outros tipos de demência como é o
caso da demência de copos de li como é o
caso da demência front temporal
e outras doenças mais raras como
hidrocefalia de pressão normal como
também a demência de cacof que são mais
raras esses
casos seja qual for demena ela era
caracterizada por um declino de memória
na linguagem na resolução de problemas
outras habilidades cognitivas que vão
caindo e que afetam a capacidade de uma
pessoa atuar para realizar tarefas
cotidianas para poder estar sendo
funcional Então como tô dizendo aqui a
demência não é doença única é um termo
geral que descreve uma ampla Gama de
sintomas existem vários tipos de
demência Como já falei o Alzheimer mais
comum mais conhecido além da demência de
corpos de l a fron temporal a
hidrocefalia de pressão normal e corsac
falei temos também a demência vascular
só que hoje tá cada vez mais difícil
você separar a demência vascular do
Alzheimer Porque existe o subtipo
vascular dentro do Alzheimer então
existi uma separação muito clara
antigamente entre demência vascular e
Alzheimer E hoje nós sabemos que são
Entrelaçados O componente vascular é um
componente importante do
Alzheimer então a patologia de Alzheimer
ela é caracterizado pela acumulação de
proteínas disformes são
agregados de proteínas Formes proteínas
que se dobraram de maneira errada que
estão tortas que nós chamamos de placa
amiloide e emaranhado neurofibrilar de
tal Ok então tem as proteínas tal e a
betamil Loide que acumula no cérebro
atrapalha o funcionamento dos neurônios
e não permite que o sinal elétrico passe
adequadamente do neurônio pro outro isso
vai causar disrupção da maneira como a
gente pensa como
raciocina
então quanto menos conexão tiver entre
os neurônios menos inteligência menos
cognição é justamente essas proteínas
alteradas vão atrapalhando a comunicação
entre os
neuros a presença dessas
patologias das demencias nem sempre se
correlacionam com a
gravidade dos sintomas Ou seja a a
presença
da proteínas disformes nem sempre ela
está direta ente relacionada à gravidade
tem gente que tem mais copos amiloides
tem mais proteína asal e não tem tanto
comprometimento do sistema nervoso
central então é uma situação complexa
você não pode fazer uma correlação tão
Clara entre a piora cognitiva da pessoa
com a presença dessas proteínas porque
não existe uma correlação exata entre
uma coisa e outra um equívoco comum é
que a demência é uma parte inevitável do
envelhecimento mas não é o caso embora a
idade seja um fator de risco muito
significativo a demência não é uma parte
normal do envelhecimento é crucial
diferenciar entre mudanças na memória
relacionadas à idade como recordação
mais lenta ou necessidade mais tempo
para aprender coisas novas normal do
envelhecimento e as deficiências de
memória mais graves que vão sinalizar a
demência então compreender essas
diferenças é vital para detecção
intervenção
precoce Além disso existe uma relação
entre coisas que estão sendo estudadas
hoje em dia são mais recentes são mais
modernas por exemplo uma substância
muito importante na formação da membrana
celular especialmente da membrana
celular dos neurônios são sons
plasmalógenos ou
plasmalogenos essas substâncias são
derivados da
gordura que você tira do ômega3 que você
tira do ômega-6 e elas têm um papel
muito importante sinalização no cérebro
Então tá sendo estudado nos últimos 10
anos muito esses
plasmalogenos e os estudos
principalmente do Dr Dean ou
di né não sei como é que pronúncia
exatamente o sobrenome dele mas é good
know Dian good know então ele tem um
livro sobre esse estudo dos paralogos
ele propõe também que você faça exames
para definir a quantidade desse
paralogos que você tem no seu organismo
para saber se tá em deficiência e você
pode repor com ômega-3 ou com plasm
halogênio derivado do ômega-3 que é uma
maneira mais sofisticada de você tá
repondo essas substâncias são
importantes na sinalização entre os
neurônios então a investigação sugere
que níveis elevados de certos
plasmalogenos se você aumentar a
quantidade desses plasmalogenos você
pode neutralizar os efeitos negativos
mesmo que você tenha a genética ruim no
apoe4 tá essa genética do apoe4 se você
tiver uma cópia você aumenta quatro
vezes a chance de ter doença duas cópias
aumentem até 16 vezes então isso é um
estudo sendo feito que tá bem
interessante que para você repor o
plasmalogen né que tem uma empresa
americana que tem várias empresas mas
tem essa empresa americana eh que vende
de spog que é mais confiável e que a
gente pode tá utilizando esse produto
Infelizmente ainda não tem no Brasil tem
que ser importado
Ok então existe um potencial para novas
vias de prevenção e tratamento
enfatizando a importância da
investigação contínua e da investigação
científica sobre o mecanismo de demência
Então embora a perda de memória possa
fazer parte do processo normal de
envelhecimento a demena representa um
grupo de sintomas suficientemente graves
para interferir na vida diária Então
precisamos compreender as nuances dessas
condições e assim reconhecer melhor os
sinais e tomar as medidas adequadas tá
então quais seriam essas medidas papel
do estilo de vida é o principal ponto
aqui que nós precisamos
conversar então descobrimos que as
nossas escolhas diárias T implicações
impactos profundos sobre a saúde do
cérebro então no livro que eu li em 2017
logo que
lançou o programa do fim do Alzheimer Na
verdade o primeiro livro foi o fim do
Alzheimer e 2 3 anos depois lançou o
programa do fim do Alzheimer foi o
segundo livro do de BR então esses dois
livros eles oferecem um protocolo
abrangente que pode ressaltar a
importância da dieta dos exercícios do
Sono do gerenciamento do estresse e
também dos exercícios
cerebrais manutenção da função cogn
tá até um comentário aqui já vou até
falar aqui a mcia sou leiga não entendo
nada então mcia o que que eu vou falar
aqui vou falar de coisas que você pode
fazer no dia a dia
prevenir ou tratar quadros iniciais de
Alzheimer de maneira que você possa
começar a reverter esse processo e a
doença e ela coloca é genética sim A
genética tem um papel mas genética não é
sentença Genética é tendência Tá certo e
o outad não sei se assim que pronunciei
o seu nome desculpa mas seu nome depois
você pode até falar como é que fala o
valad ou
outad esquecimento e falha de memória é
sinal de perda de memória sim é sinal de
perda de memória mas tem o linear do
normal do envelhecimento e do do da pré
demência que seria o d cognitivo leve e
a demência que já o com moderado ou
acentuado né e a pergunta da mim buquer
pessoas com depressão podem ter demência
as duas coisas estão muito entrelaçadas
então muitas vezes a depressão é
confundida com demência mas pessoas que
estão no quadro inicial de demência
também podem ter depressão então é
confuso muitas vezes você diferenciar
uma coisa da outra você dizer quem tem
depressão sem demência e quem tem
demência com depressão não é simples
isso daí mas as duas coisas estão
relacionadas
né temos várias perguntas aqui do Eliseu
Mas eu vou deixar para responder depois
tá
Eliseu Então a primeira coisa que nós
estamos que falar que é o mais
importante é a dieta tá a dieta
desempenha um papel
essencial fundamental na saúde do
cérebro Esse é sempre o ponto mais
difícil que eu tenho
que convencer os pacientes a mudar uma
dieta que tá errada há muitos anos tá
Qual que é a dieta que a gente propõe
uma dieta baseado em vegetais baseada em
gordura saudável com proteína moderada e
com pouquíssimo carboidrato essa dieta é
uma variação da dieta
cetogênica só que a gente chama dieta
ketoflex tá ketoflex é um termo que F do
todeio Breath que
desenvolveu Por que que ketoflex
ketoflex porque o Flex vem da intenção
de induzir o organismo a queimar de
maneira tão eficiente a gordura como ele
queima a glicose Então o que acontece
muitas vezes na maior parte dos
pacientes que T resistência insulínica
pré-diabetes e desenvolve um quadro
cognitivo ele tem uma resistência
insulínica no cérebro o cérebro tem
dificuldade de queimar açúcar mesmo
sobrando açúcar como é que a gente faz
para esse cérebro voltar a ser saudável
ele passa a ser um cérebro que queima de
maneira eficiente tanto açúcar glicose
quanto derivado da gordura que são os
copos cetônicos e os triglicérides Então
tem que fazer beta oxidação que é queima
de gordura e tem que fazer a queima da
cetose dos copos cetônicos também de uma
maneira adequada Então essa dieta
ketoflex que tem em em média 12 a 16
horas de jejum por dia 3 horas de
período que você fica de jejum entre a
última refeição hora de deitar por isso
que tem esse nomezinho dieta ketoflex
12/3 é um componente
chave e precisa ser uma dieta rica em
plantas por que isso porque as plantas
têm vários polifenóis tem várias
substâncias interessantes que vão ajudar
na microbiota intestinal de maneira que
as bactérias sejam diversas
diversificadas e que elas produzam
substâncias adequadas paraa saúde Nossa
que é o órgão virtual que nós temos no
nosso organismo que é o microbioma então
é importante comer gordura saudável é
importante comer vegetais e é importante
ter um aporte suficiente de
proteína Então essa forma deação foi
concebida para maximizar o fornecimento
de combustível pro cérebro para que o
cérebro possa queimar glicose e gordura
da mesma maneira eficiente poder queimar
os copos cetônicos permitindo essa
flexibilidade de onde vem o Tero
ketoflex E aí você pode se incluir
produtos de origem animal com base as
suas preferências e necessidades mas é
perfeitamente possível também fazer uma
dieta vegana rica em gordura vegetal de
boa procedência qual que a gordura
vegetal de boa procedência azeite de
oliva extravirgem óleo de amêndoas que
não seja processado óleo de coco óleo de
abacate Então essas gorduras são boas
gorduras que não são inflamatórias ag o
que que é uma gordura vegetal por
exemplo ruim inflamatória é o óleo de
soja que tem muita gordura trans para
não ficar ruim não estragar o óleo eles
colocam gordura trans é o óleo de milho
é o óleo canola esses óleos são
processados são adicionados gorduras
trans Então são óleos que são
problemáticos Não não é toda a gordura
vegetal que é boa e não é toda a gordura
animal que é
ruim e pra gente poder induzir a cetose
que é o processo que o organismo pega a
gordura e transforma em corpos
cetônicos A gente precisa de jejum
precisa de atividade física e precisa
reduzir carboidrato então o jejum é
importante também nessa dieta mínimo de
12 horas então qual que é o ponto aqui
jantar cedo e tomar café da manhã tarde
tá jantar cedo 6 horas da tarde 7 horas
da noite e depois você toma um café da
manhã 12 horas depois então Digamos que
você jantou às 6 horas terminou de
jantar 6:30 você pode tomar o café da
manhã se for fazer 12 horas de jejum às
7 horas da manhã agora Digamos que você
quer estender esse jejum para 14 horas
você já não vai poder tomar o café da
manhã às 7 tem que tomar às 9 então tem
essa esse período para quem que é
recomendado fazer o jejum de 14
horas ou de 16 horas pessoas que têm uma
cópia do apoi 4 por isso que é
interessante fazer o exame genético é
melhor fazer 14 horas pessoas que têm
duas cópias api quatro é melhor fazer 16
horas de jejum e esse intervalo de 3
horas entre a última refeição o jantar e
a hora de dormir também faz diferença
tem estudos mostrando que pessoas que
fazem alimentação muito tarde da noite
tem menos saúde que as pessoas que
jantam cedo então faz diferença essa
cronobiologia esse horário que você vai
se
alimentar Tá então não se trata somente
do que nós comemos Mas também de quando
e como comemos criando o estilo de vida
que vai dar suporte à saúde metabólica e
consequentemente a função cerebral eu
essa parte de dieta é muito
detalhezinho então que que seria então o
café da manhã cetogênico comer abacate
comer ovos comer castanhas nozes e
amêndoas comer salada comer legumes usar
bastante azeite de oliva colocar um óleo
de coco no Café tem cortado esse café da
manhã pão batata doce tapioca mandioca
esses alimentos saem do café da
manhã então é uma dieta que para muitas
pessoas especialmente pessoas que tem um
hábito muito arraigado de comer pão de
manhã cedo ou comer tapioca de manhã
cedo é uma dieta que pode ser sofrida
para essas pessoas mas que tem um
benefício uma recompensa muito maior que
o sacrifício almoço mesma coisa come uma
salada come legumes azeite de oliva você
pode colocar noz de Castanha você pode
colocar abacate você pode temperar com
especiarias com temperos naturais sal
integral sal rosa ou sal Celta ou sal
marinho
integral Então as especiarias são muito
boas esses temperos naturais a de
masterchef excelentes paraa saúde
cerebral e tentar fazer duas refeições
Ou no máximo três por dia porém dando
esse falo de jejum antes da gente falar
do exercício físico eu vou responder
algumas perguntas de vocês ok vamos ao
Eliseu que já deixou um monte de
pergunta aqui desde o começo da
Live Vamos mostrar as perguntas aqui
qual a minha opinião sobre o curso de
leitura dinâmica e memorização e
capacita o aluno a ler um livro em uma
hora então eu já fiz curso de leitura
dinâmica e memorização a minha opinião
sobre isso Eliseu é o seguinte vale a
pena fazer Vale contanto que
você entenda o seguinte Eh
esses cursos que prometem que você vai
ler um livro inteiro em uma hora você
consegue ler um livro inteiro em uma
hora consegue mas a sua apreensão a sua
compreensão vai ser pequena se for um
livro muito cheio de informação que você
não precisa e que você quer ter uma
visão geral um apanhado geral daquele
livro vale a pena mas entenda que a
pessoa que faz um curso desse tem que
entender que precisa
coordenar o tempo que você vai gastar
naquilo ali com a densidade da
informação e com a importância da
informação então você pode ler um livro
em uma hora pode mas você vai pegar
muito pouco informação daquele livro se
for um livro importante é melhor que
você gar 5 horas porque você vai tirar
um conhecimento muito relevante daquilo
lá então recomendo que faça assim para
aprender técnicas de memorização e de
por exemp o até de Palácio na memória é
muito interessante de memorização e que
você aumente a velocidade de leitura mas
não para você ficar batendo recorde
porque isso é bobagem
tá o momento em que a pessoa fixa na
memória aquilo que aprendeu no sono
vem a literatura diz que sim mas isso
ainda tá em estudo pode ser que tenha um
sono profundo também tem um papel nisso
daí é verdade que existe suplemento para
memória curta e suplemento para memória
longa Não não é uma Não é bem assim não
Eliseu suplementos que melhoram a
memória melhoram as duas memórias a
curta e a longa
tá luta de box pode causar pedo de
memória sim então é um bom momento para
eu falar dos tipos de Alzheimer Você tem
o tipo inflamatório ou tipo atrófico o
que que é o inflamatório né Tá pegando
fogo no seu cérebro porque tá inflamado
com infecção ou porque você tá
e exposto a várias substâncias aí no
meio
ambiente que causa inflamação o seu
cérebro tem o tipo atrófico tá faltando
eh adubo pro seu cérebro como se fosse
uma horta tá faltando adubo Então tá
faltando alguns hormônios alguns fatores
de crescimento neuronal esse fator
atrófico tipo atrófico o tipo glico
atrófico que é o tipo diabético diabetes
cerebral resistência insulínica cerebral
Então são três tipos que eu falei até
agora né atrófico inflamatório e o glico
atrófico que é o Diabetes cerebral e nós
temos também o tipo vascular que é falta
de irrigação sanguínea o tipo tóxico e o
tipo traumático né são seis tipos Então
esse tipo traumático é justamente o tipo
que você acabou de falar jogador de
futebol americano pessoas que lutaram
Box eh pessoas que por algum motivo
sofreram traumas repetidos sofreram
muito acidente automóvel e bateu muito a
cabeça sim é um fator importante no
déficit cognitivo
no uma das causas da do Alzheimer tá e
outras demências
também isso não tem prazo Eliseu prazo
mínimo não tem nem prazo mínimo nem
prazo máximo Tá depende muito que a
pessoa tá aderindo Digamos que a pessoa
aderiu de maneira muito firme ao prog
prama tá fazendo dieta jejum atividade
física atividade cerebral tá fazendo
meditação e relaxamento e tá fazendo o
sono adequado tudo certo você pode ter
estado com um mês ou com seis meses ou
se você não tá fazendo nada certo aí
você vai demorar mais de um ano para ter
qualquer resultado porque você tá
fazendo pela metade
né Já falamos das seis causas de
Alzheimer a mais difícil ser curada é a
tóxica tá porque é mais difícil de
investigar porque você tem que fazer
exames que muitas vezes não estão
disponíveis de maneira fácil tanto metal
pesado quanto poluente orgânico quanto
poluente que vem de micotoxinas toxina
de fungo esses três grupos de toxinas é
difícil de você investigar então o mais
difícil de tratar é o tóxico o segundo
mais difícil de tratar
é o vascular
tá B12 é bom te manter pelo menos
550 entre 550 e 1500 tá E no não é para
curar para é um dos muitos fatores tem
que ser corrigidos para melhorar essa
pessoa
tá o fato me pensou ter ap E4 significa
que se decidente também serão não porque
a pessoa pode ter uma cópia só de a P4 a
o parceiro ou a parceira ter não ter
pode ser por exemplo apoi E2 barra apo
E3 e Juntando os dois um filho pode ter
apo E4 e out e os outros filhos não
terem apoi qu tá então A genética não
funciona assim então pode acontecer de
passar ou não passar o apoi
quro a posição corporal a melhor posição
corporal para dormir Eliseu é de lado
porque facilita o funcionamento do
cérebro e do coração e do pulmão Tá mas
eh não não conheço estudos que falem
assim que o cara que dormiu de lado tem
menos caso ou não de Alzheimer que o
cara que dorme de bruço esse po até que
exista mas não conheço um beijo no seu
coração também viu
Vilma bem Já respondi algumas perguntas
Deixa eu voltar aqui para minha
exposição a gente volta para responder
as mais perguntas aqui na
frente então vamos falar do exercício
agora agora falamos da alimentação vamos
falar do exercício se vocês tiverem
dúvidas da alimentação por favor
perguntem tá essa Live é para ser
dinâmica para eu trocar bastante coisa
com vocês o exercício é outra Pedra
Angular é outro ponto fundamental da
Saúde cognitiva a atividade física
Especialmente quando ela é combinada com
uma dieta saudável dieta ketoflex
12/3 que eu acabei de falar e o jejum
ela pode levar um efeito sinérgico ela
vai permitir que a cetose aconteça de
uma maneira muito mais
eficiente e isso a dieta com atividade
física em conjunto tem um papel muito
poderoso muito intenso em promover a
saúde metabólica e a função cognitiva
então o exercício regular inclusive
Depois dessa Live né minha mulher não
gosta muito mas eu vou pegar e vou na
minha academia nem que eu sai de lá meia
noite vou fazer minha academia hoje tá
isso é uma coisa que você tem que
colocar na cabeça de vocês Esquece essa
história Ai não tenho tempo tem que ter
tempo você tem que arrumar um tempo para
fazer atividade física é fundamental pra
sua saúde cerebral saúde do coração
saúde dos Ossos saúde dos músculos tudo
isso depende fundamentalmente da
atividade
física o exercício regular ele aumenta o
fluxo sanguínio pro cérebro dá suporte
ao crecimento de novas conexões neurais
ou seja ela vai ter um efeito
sinap blástico de criar conexões neurais
e vai aumentar um hormônio cerebral que
na verdade mais um fator neurotrófico
chamado
bdnf que é o Brain derived neurotropic
Vector essa proteína vai dar suporte a
conexões e mais neurônios e aumentar a
sobrevivência desses neurônios para que
haja maior crescimento de conexões
tá então é muito importante atividade
física que atividade física fazer faça o
básico primeiro meia hora de caminhada
por dia isso é fundamental aí depois que
você criar uma rotina de meia hora de
caminhada coloca musculação ou um
pilates ou um CrossFit junto musculação
tem que ser no mínimo três vezes semana
ou equivalente poderia ser CrossFit ou í
funcional ou mesmo o pilates então
aeróbico todo dia
caminhada mesmo gente coisa simples pega
lá um tênis velho você vai andar na rua
ou se a sua rua for perigosa anda na
esteira se você mora em prédio anda na
esteira Hoje quase todos os prédios tem
uma mini academia que você tem uma
esteira lá que você pode andar ou um
elíptico né então tem que fazer aeróbico
bicicleta É uma opção interessante
natação se você tiver acesso a piscina
meia hora todo dia de
aeróbic então fazer de S 1 a 10.000
Passos por dia Então arruma um reloginho
que mede os passos tem uns relógios aí
baratos chineses né Não vou falar marcas
aqui que eu não vou fazer propaganda de
marca mas você conhecem aí tem que Emi
não sei o que lá não vou entrar em
detalhes Tá mas vocês podem estar
utilizando um relógio que mé de Passos
7.000 a 10.000 Passos por dia e isso é
muito importante então fazer os 7.000 a
10.000 Passos por dia ou a natação o
ciclismo equivalente ou e fazer os três
dias por semana de musculação vamos
falar um pouquinho do sono também então
a qualidade do sono não pode ser
exagerada quando a gente está falando de
saúde cognitiva é uma coisa que as
pessoas ao longo dos anos vê
negligenciando ah mas dormir é perder
tempo dormir não é perder tempo dormir é
ganhar tempo porque você ganha
produtividade Você trabalha com mais
eficácia mais
eficiência Tudo melhora na sua vida
quando o seu sono melhora então uma base
de sono de qualidade essencial pro
cérebro reparar e consolidar memórias
padrões de sono de forma inadequada
estão associadas a maior risco de
declínio cognitivo e podem agravar a
confusão mental e os problemas de
memória então o programa o recode o Dr
de braden desenvolveu e que eu Também
pratico no Brasil enfatiza a importância
de otimizar o sono para dar suporte a
cognição sugerindo que o horário de sono
consistente e um ambiente propício são
cruciais que que seria interessante
Então não vá dormir depois das 11 horas
da
noite então você vai
deitar no máximo às 11 horas da noite o
ideal que você deitasse às 10 horas da
noite se você mora no campo ou se você
pode dormir mais cedo Melhor ainda então
se você mora numa área rural ou você
pode você tem essa facilidade de dormir
cedo vai dormir 9 horas da noite até às
vezes tem alguns pacientes meus que não
dormir a 8 horas da noite ele vai dormir
a 8 da noite e acorda à 4 da manhã eu
sei que isso não é realidade paraa
maioria das pessoas mas eu penso que
para você que quer prevenir essa doença
Vá dormir no máximo 11 horas da noite e
vai dormir pelo menos 7 horas de entre 7
a 8 horas de sono de
qualidade então se você tem um sono
muito leve ou se você acorda no meio da
madrugada com muita
frequência converse com o médico
converse com o profissional de saúde
para você poder corrigir isso daí
meditação que o próximo ponto nós vamos
abordar uma coisa que ajuda muito a você
melhorar a qualidade do sono então
meditação relaxamento vai ajudar você
você dormir
melhor então sono adequado uma hora
antes de dormir você desliga as telas
acesas desliga as luzes vai tomar um
banho relaxante vai paraa sua cama faz
seu relaxamento sua oração você pode
associar a
oração com meditação fazer as duas
coisas em conjunto e digamos que você
tem dificuldade de pegar no sono você
pode ligar uma luz de cabeira
fazer uma leitura de um livro de uma
revista de algum assunto que te
interessa o ideal que seja um assunto
leve para que você possa pegar no sono
porque ver tela acesa Tem gente que fala
ah eu sou DMO vendo televisão é péssimo
televisão tem aquela luz azul que vai te
induzir a ter um som de má qualidade vai
atrapalhar a produção de melatonina
então não faça isso de cendo televisão
tire a televisão do quarto se você tiver
coloca na sala e outro cômodo e não cria
esse hábito de ficar vendo tela acesa na
hora de dormir atrapalha o seu sono Ok
podemos falar mais do Sono se houver
perguntas aí a respeito disso deixa eu
responder mais algumas perguntas depois
V partir pro gerenciamento do
estresse Boa noite novamente as pessoas
que entraram nessa a Live eu não tinha
dado a saudação anteriormente porque
vocês não tinham entrado
ainda tem um comentário aqui de Ari já
utilizei com resultados notórios em
casos de Alzheimer fase dois adesivos de
nicotina sim existe estudos mostrando
que a nicotina tem um
efeito
interessante para aumentar a circulação
cerebral Veja Bem pessoal que tá estamos
falando de nicotina é isolada não tem
nada a ver de fumar bom ou de mascar
tabaco ou de cheirar rapé é a nicotina
medicamentosa
ok uma colher de sopa de azeite de oliva
extravirgem éem excesso não não acredito
ser excesso não viu
Eliseu tem um comentário aqui também
doari quanto mais prolongada for a
primeira refeição do dia melhor o ideal
é iniciar a primeira refeição às 11
horas e a última refeição às 18 é isso
não é ainda um fato escrito em pedra ali
se você fizer às 14 ou 16 horas de jejum
não é tão importante o horário que você
vai quebrar o jejum tá mais importante o
tempo de jejum e sim você tem razão você
tem que mastigar bem o alimento 20 vezes
comer devagar e existe pessoas que fazem
só uma refeição por dia tá que é o omad
Né One me a day tem gente que consegue
fazer isso e se sente muito bem mas eu
acho que não é que todo mundo precise
necessariamente fazer só uma refeição ao
dia ou duas refeições ao dia se
conseguir fazer de 12 a 16 horas de
jejum já tá fazendo muita
coisa a batata doce sacia junto com ovos
sim Bastos eh se você ainda não
tem déficit cognitivo ou é bem leve
ainda você pode restringir menos
carboidrato que uma pessoa que está com
quadro de demência já
instituído o ovo é um alimento que dá
muita saciedade Eu particularmente tomo
meu café da manhã dois ou três ovos e
não como mais nenhum carboidrato agora
não há nenhum problema de você colocar
batata doce contanto que você esteja com
a Glicemia ideal uma glicemia baixo de
90 em jejum com uma hemoglobina glicada
abaixo de 5.3 a minha glicada é 4.7
4.8 já chegou até 4.6 tá é muito baixo
glicada a minha Glicemia de jejum é por
volta de 70 e alguma coisa então eu
tenho essa benção de associar uma
genética boa com hábitos de vida bom
então eu consigo ter uma glicemia muito
baixa então
mas pessoas que já estão com quadro
inicial de demência Essa batata doce já
pode fazer uma diferença e de ser
carboidrato demais essas pessoas que não
conseguem metabolizar de maneira
adequada o
carboidrato paraa memória Tenho usado
óleo de coco extv Sim é muito bom que
comentei agora a pouco ovos e algumas
ervas estão melhorando sim ervas são
excelentes como eu tava falando são os
especiar né os temperos
naturais essa pergunta Luciana é muito
variável tá eh a gente pode falar um
pouco mais de suplementos daqui a pouco
mas eu quero que vocês entendam que o
fundamental é o estilo de vida tá
suplemento pode variar muito o estilo de
vida não varia tanto
assim obrigado viu o seu acompanhamento
aí da
Holanda
Fiquei sabendo que o consumo de B12
diminui a quantidade de ferro no
corpo não tô sabendo essa informação
Eliseu se você tiver a fonte depois você
mostra que eu não conheço essa
informação essa questão de quanto de
bikol você vai ingerir vai depender
muito de de como é que tá a sua saúde e
se você vai conseguir realmente
processar metabol ar esse binol todo tá
tem estudos mostrando doses bem altas de
com enzima q10 não binol mas A bikin ona
para uí renal por
exemplo mas o custo aumenta bastante eu
acho que 200 mg paraa maioria das
pessoas já tá
suficiente uma boa pergunta como é que
diferenciar os Ram de outras demências
tem várias formas de fazer isso eh um
exame que é bem útil para isso é o Pet
Scan com fdg pet fdg Pet o que que é
eh é uma glicose marcada com flua
radioativo tá então você faz esse exame
essa glicose marcada ela vai cumular nas
regiões do cérebro estão mais ativas e
onde não tiver captação
adequada desse marcador é onde tá
faltando o metabolismo cerebral então
por exemplo você faz exame e a região
frontal e temporal estão deficientes em
relação ao resto do cérebro isso sugere
nem sempre fecha diagnóstico mas sugere
uma demência PR temporal agora Digamos
que o padrão é temporal e parietal aí já
sugere mais um quadro de alheimer tá se
o padrão fori parietooccipital
isso já sugere mais uma demência de
corpos de li Mas isso não é 100% mas já
dá uma ideia bem razoável do tipo de
demência tá hoje nós temos também um
exame de sangue que antes só dava para
ver impulsão de líc né de líquido céfalo
raquidiano e você identificar ali
fragmentos Bet amiloide aí você poder
falar que aquilo er um anheim hoje tem
um exame de sangue que lançou mais ou
menos um ano e meio que você pode est e
inferindo pela quantidade de betamil né
da da da fração do betamil que tá
ali se a pessoa tem ou não tem alzer
também é outro
jeito
tem algumas perguntas aqui que não são
direcionadas ao tema de hoje eu vou
pular tá nós estamos falando hoje de
saúde cognitiva e não de saúde
digestiva tô aqui olhando as perguntas
pessoal uma pergunta interessante Ariela
Boa noite Doutor o azul de metileno
previne Alzheimer Sim é muito bom eu uso
azul de metileno por que que eu uso eu
tenho quatro casos na família de doença
de alheimer por isso que eu me interesso
muito por esse tema e foi que me motivou
a ler o livro do Dr Day Brad em 2017
naquela época fiquei muito
gratificado porque tudo que eu tava
lendo aquele livro era o que eu tava
estudando na época de medicina funcional
saúde funcional e medicina integrativa
então o azul de metileno é muito
interessante porque ele baixa o açúcar
do sangue ele é
anti-inflamatório e ele ajuda no
transporte de elétrons na cas
fosforilativa na mitocôndria então ele
tem vários mecanismos
diferentes que ajudam na prevenção do
Alzheimer então sim eu recomendo Azul
metileno nós temos vídeos sobre esse
assunto no canal eu faço a o uso do
azulim metileno junto com an naltrexone
de baixo dosagem para maximizar essa
questão de prevenção de inflamação
cerebral meu marido e eu estamos com a
memória ruim ele começou a tomar com
enzima que10 com vitamina e e o que que
podemos tomar não temos como ir agora
uma consulta tá vamos falar dos
Suplementos daqui a pouco tá os
principais suplementos Tá mas eu posso
dizer para você que coa que 10 sim é um
dos principais vitamina e tem vários
chipos tem oito tipos de vitamina e eu
optaria pelos tocotrienóis
os tocotrienóis eles têm uma ação
antioxidante antiinflamatória mais
intensa do que os toc feroz então tanto
Gama quanto Delta quantro enol é mais
potente que as outras formas
tá será que batata doce com leite de
Castanha à noite é bom
leite de Castanha é uma boa alternativa
para leite de vaca que é
inflamatório tem pessoas que tem
intolerância Castanha tem que levar isso
em consideração e batata doce já
comentei tem pessoas que se dão bem
batata doce e outras nem tanto
dependendo do grau que você tem de
resistência insulínica e de tolerância a
carboidrato Boa noite
cásia ten usado Glutamina paraa questão
gastrointestinal porém tenho notado uma
melhora da memória e na saciedade de
doce carboidratos Existe algum estudo
comprovando tem a Glutamina ela é uma
substância interessante aminoácido que é
muito bom para imunidade e para a saúde
intestinal Então como você melhora a
saúde intestinal pela conexão que tem
entre o intestino e o cérebro você
melhora também a saúde cerebral então
tem a ver sim tá e a Glutamina ela dá
uma saciedade sim e ajuda a controlar
essa compulsão por
doces A tá repetida a
pergunta meu pai e minha mãe tem
Alzheimer Qual exame eu deveria fazer
para saber se estou no caminho exame
para diagnóstico tá eu comentei aqui do
Pet Scan fdg Pet né e comentei do exame
de sangue para buscar os fragmentos do
do betamil Loide né são exames para
diagnóstico tem que fazer um um perfil
bioquímico geral para ver a saúde da
pessoa tem que ver pesquisar metais
pesados na urina e no
sangue fazer uma polissonografia para
ver se a pessoa não tem apnea do
sono então tem uma outra uma série de
outros exames que tem que fazer para ver
a saúde geral dessa pessoa que vai
influenciar no
cérebro e é muito frequente os
cuidadores terem problema viu viu jandra
então se cuide sim se cuide Não deixe se
cuidar porque os cuidadores se estressam
muito e começa a ter até declin de
memória por causa desse estresse Então
se cuide tá e não fique
sobrecarregado o que comer às 18 horas
para não sentir fome para quem vai se
deitar as 23 com uma gordura saudável
use óleo de coco azeite de de oliva nos
e castanhas abacate isso dá saciedade
ovos dão dão saciedade comer carne
vermelha com moderação Não coma demais
então gordura e proteína é o que dá
saciedade tá Se você prestar atenção se
você comer pão 3 horas depois tá com
fome de novo não conte com carboidrato
para te dar essa ansiedade que dá edade
proteína e
gordura quando diminui o cab Tem insônia
Severa Só uso carboidrato
complexo Existe uma forma para melhorar
esse problema vai diminuindo aos
pouquinhos o carboidrato e usa
carboidrato complexo marada doce
Miami
mandioca arroz negro arroz vermelho
quinua tá use carboidrato
complexo para
poder e diminuindo aos pouquinhos e vai
aumentando a gordura com o tempo você
vai acostumar o seu corpo vai começar a
queimar a gordura de maneira mais
eficiente e você já não vai ter mais
essa insônia
Ok você poderia falar um pouquinho da
perda de memória das pessoas que tiveram
covid
tá não sei nem se é bom falar desse
assunto eu tive muito problema no meu
canal para esse assunto recentemente Eu
soltei um vídeo sobre de trombose
tromboembolismo no canal e a gente não
pode nem tocar num assunto que você sabe
qual que é mas muita gente tem pelo
menos umas 30 pessoas que falaram a é
por causa daquilo que tá acontecendo
essas tromboses é por causa daquilo né
Então pessoal eu prefiro não falar muito
desse assunto mas eu posso dizer que
esse vírus
aí ele sim ele tem causado falei em
lives anteriores em vídeos anteriores
sobre a questão da do efeito da proteí
spik tem na memória e na no D cognitivo
sim pessoas que TM covid longa tem queda
de memória queda de cognição essa
proteína Spike que tá por aí de várias
formas né
Tem
ocasionado queda de cognição queda de
fluxo cerebral né então é muito
importante você que tá com covid longa
que você faça tratamento adequado tem
tem vídeos falando desse assunto no
canal bromelina naak Nat kinas
eh dente de leão puncho tem várias aí eh
elementos que vão te ajudar a se livrar
aí dos problemas relacionados a proteína
Spike Tá mas eu prefiro falar pouco
sobre esse assunto porque já tive muito
problema quase perdi o canal por causa
disso
sim oni eu faço consulta online sim
viu esse assunto Maria É bem
interessante o hidrogênio molecular eu
acho que ele é muito interessante como
antioxidante
né ele ajuda sim na questão cerebral se
você tiver acesso a uma inalação com
hidrogênio
Eu sugiro que você
faça caso você queira fazer uma
Prevenção ou até mesmo um tratamento um
D cognitivo
leve bem deixa eu voltar aqui pro
texto vamos falar do gerenciamento do
estresse então essencial que você
gerencie o estresse para prevenir e
também para tratar o declínio cognitivo
o estresse crônico pode causar
inflamação desequilíbrios hormonais que
afetam negativamente a função do cérebro
existe várias técnicas que você pode est
lançando
mão não necessariamente você tem que
mudar de religião tem muita gente que
faz confusão e acha que meditação é
coisa de budista Gente Não Precisa Mudar
de religião mesmo que você seja Angélico
você pode fazer sua oração e adotar
técnica de respiração profunda em
conjunto com a oração é muito importante
experimentar oxigenação do cérebro e
para reduzir os níveis de estresse
existe estudos mostrando que a meditação
e relaxamento baixam os marcadores
inflamatórios então respiração profunda
associado a oração já é uma meditação e
também você ter contato com a natureza
você ter um banho de natureza um banho
de Floresta tem estudo mostrando você
fazer passeios ao em meio à natureza
caminhadas respirando um ar mais puro
você pode fazer mindfulness que que é
mindful nem precisa fechar os olhos para
meditar você pode est vivenciando aquele
momento sem pensar no passado e no
futuro e respirando profundamente Isso
já é o mindfulness então tem cursos eh é
para te ensinar a praticar o mindfulness
né é vivenciar o momento com Plenitude
sem ficar ansioso pensando no futuro ou
ficar remoendo o passado então fazer uma
caminhada ao ar livre com respiração
profunda ouvindo um mantra ouvindo um
canto gregoriano ouvindo qualquer tipo
de gravação que te leve a um estado mais
profundo de consciência é muito
interessante isso daí
prática de hobbies saudáveis né seria
uma coisa interessante para você reduzir
o seu stress
também então a própria atividade física
vai reduzir o seu
stresse você ter contato com conteúdo de
alta qualidade com informações precisas
que você possa Então tá agregando a A
Sua rotina é muito importante também
para que você
possa reduzir o
stresse Então pessoal a incorporação
desses estilos todos que nós estamos
falando esses modificações elementos
estilo de vida são muito poderosos
alimentação atividade física o
gerenciamento do Sono gerenciamento do
estresse são coisas que vão dar
condições pro seu organismo ismo eh se
recuperar né então coma os alimentos
certos Pratic atividade física dê
prioridade ao sono dê prioridade
gerenciamento do estresse que isso vai
ser muito importante para dar suporte à
saúde do cérebro à medida que a gente
vai envelhecendo tá vamos falar um pouco
mais sobre técnicas de redução de
estresse mudar o nosso foco o papel de
estilo de vida na prevenção do estilo
prevenção do declínio cognitivo
é muito importante porque assim nós
descobrimos que as nossas escolhas
diárias têm implicações Profundas paraa
saúde do cérebro o livro Dr de brads o
programa do fim do Alzheimer então Ele
oferece um protocolo abrangente que
ressalta a importância desses elementos
que nós
falamos da dieta do exercício do sono e
do controle do
estresse
tem uma aspecto que eu não falei ainda
que é a vida social que é muito
importante hoje nós estamos vivendo
muito isolados uns dos outros por mais
que a gente se conecte nas redes sociais
as pessoas estão perdendo a
conexão entre umas e outras na vida de
sociedade
então é muito importante que você
procure se reconectar as pessoas ter o
hábito de frequentar grupos que tem
interesses em comum por exemplo é uma
coisa muito interessante que eu vejo
aqui em São Paulo são os night bikers né
o pessoal que se junta para fazer
atividade física e tem também aquele
eh contato social Então procure um grupo
e tem afinidade com você tanto na
atividade física quanto interesse de
hobes em comum né Tente se conectar com
a comunidade seja da igreja seja a
comunidade da do seu
templo do onde você frequenta a sua
religião então interagir com outras
pessoas não é só uma fonte de prazer e
conforto também é um componente Vital
paraa saúde cognitiva né Então essas
interações sociais são tão importantes
que você vê que as regiões do mundo né
as zonas azuis onde tem mais
longevidade são justamente as reg
regiões do mundo que você tem maior
contato social seja lá na na região da
Costa Rica lá seja na região da Ilha al
do arquipélago japonês lá de Okinawa
seja ali na região da Grécia naquela
Ilha da Grécia que tem a maior
longevidade todas ess comunidades estão
muito Unidas né Isso é um fator
fundamental para que você tenha
felicidade tenha prazer e que possa
então prevenir o déficit cognitivo com
essa vida em
comunidade vamos a mais perguntas
aqui
Ôi eh dá para marcar consult comigo sim
tá eh você entra em contato tá
eh no pelo Instagram que todas as
informações serão dadas por ali
tá no Instagram o contato é @dr alind
Dutra tá E também tem no site al
dutra.com ou al
uro.com Você tem todos os telefones de
contato o CRM pega no pé da gente ficar
colocando números
aqui mas eu vou colocar colocar aqui na
na tela para vocês tá o telefone de
contato é possível Alzheimer ser do tipo
atrófico puro muito difícil Simone
geralmente é uma combinação de três ou é
atrófico com inflamatório e tóxico ou é
tóxico com atrófico com glico atrófico
geralmente são três ou quatro tipos
juntos
tá Gabriela tá perguntando se é possível
falar sobre perda de memória causada
pelo abuso de
substâncias é possível reverter sim
Gabriela é possível se essa pessoa não
teve um grau de dano neurológico muito
intenso tá porque usou por muito tempo
drogas aí que tem contaminantes eh se
não for uma lesão muito acentuada é
possível
sim ela tá comentando aqui sobre música
clássica
eh Não entendi bem isso aqui sim música
clássica pode ajudar você a meditar a
relaxar Com Certeza acho que nesse
contexto você tá colocando isso
aqui bem o paciente que toma galantamina
o glive Pode tomar Vitamina K2 Pode sim
tá
é possível uma pessoa com hipotiroidismo
com muitos anos sem tratamento
desenvolver demência por falta de
hormônios sim é um dos hormônios que tá
relacionado à demência Então tem que
repor
tireoide que é uma das
causas do tipo atrófico do Alzheimer tá
não é a única causa é muito difícil ser
uma causa isolada Mas é uma das causas
que são Sign
aplicativas poderia indicar exercício
para memória SIM tem vários aplicativos
que você hoje vê Gabriela por exemplo na
na loja tanto da Apple quanto do Android
tem um aplicativo chamado lumos tá
lumos colocar aqui para vocês
verem Esse é um deles tem outros tá
então tem um
programa no Brasil já é bem conhecido de
exercício para memória e para cognição
que é o supera além do lumos é o supera
supera também tem uma versão online tem
uma versão americana que tem tradução
para português que é o Brain
HQ ou se você quiser falar inglês puro
Brain age kill né isso tem
também isso também
tem português então já te dei três
opções aí outros exercícios de memória
que você pode
fazer leituras diárias você faz a
leitura de um dois parágrafos e resume
que você leu com as suas palavras em
papel é um jeito de treinar a memória
aprender
música Dançar ajuda muito na memória
aprender dança né ritmo de
dança aprender línguas diferentes que
você não domina muito bom paraa memória
pro para
cognição jogos tá jogos eh de cartas
podem ajudar bastante também eh sudoko
nãoé o Sudoku não é acho que é sudoko
que
pronuncia tá palavras cruzadas caça
palavras tudo isso ajuda
tá a Marta está lendo o livro fim da
Alzheimer Parabéns pela
iniciativa O Eliseu tá perguntando se
teve atualização do livro fim do
alheimer teve essa
atualização do protocolo do fim da
alheimer que foi 2019 e o mais recente
livro que foi lançado foi dos casos
pessoas que relatam a melhora delas esse
Liv foi lançado ano passado eu esqueci o
nome do livro mas acho que é os
primeiros Sobreviventes de Alzheimer uma
coisa
assim
a Marta perguntando se eu auxilio uma
pessoa com protocolo auxilio sim
Marta sinto cansaço mental gerando
estresse constante tem a ver com causa
de insônia
sim insônia provoca o cansaço mental e
vai piorar o
estresse uma glicose de jejum normal e
uma insulina de jejum normal menor que
TR e uma hemoglobina glicada de 6.1 pode
indicar Alzheimer tipo 1.5 que é o tipo
glico atrófico né quea falando aqui sim
se tem hemoglobina glic 6.1 É
pré-diabetes com certeza tem resistência
insulina glicose jej normal não sei se
for abaixo de
100 que que é um glicose de jejum normal
considera ideal abaixo de 90 Se você tá
falando de uma glicose de jejum 9 C já
res insulínico uma insulina normal se a
insulina tá tão baixa assim abaixo de
três uma hemoglobina glicada 6.1 isso
geralmente é
falência de célula Beta pancreática
então provavelmente a pessoa que tem
esses números aí ela
tem Ela já tem uma dificuldade de
produzir insulina já é um padrão
parecido com o diabet tipo
um
essa é uma pergunta muito
relevante pessoa que pesa muito pouco
também não sei a altura dela vamos dizer
que ela tem 1,5 M mesmo assim tá pesando
muito pouco né como fazer cetogênica
Nesse
caso tem que tentar dar o máximo de
gordura possível para essa pessoa tá e
ver se ela tolera tem que dar enzimas
digestivas pancreatina lipase para
conseguir
eh processar conseguir
digerir essas gorduras e absorver Se não
for possível engordar ela só com gordura
saudável aí vai ter que entrar com
batata doce com
inami
mandioca arroz negro arroz vermelho
essas fontes de carboidratos aí que são
digestão mais
lenta e é muito importante sim fazer
atividade física musculação Se for
possível como ele tá dizendo
aqui falando um pouco mais sobre o
contato social que é uma coisa que a
gente perdeu muito nos últimos anos
existem pesquisas que mostrou que tem um
Impacto Profundo a a ligação social
genuína não é aquela de rede social na
nossa longevidade e na cuidade mental
então se você tem uma rede social
robusta isso vai atuar como um uma
barreira contra os estressores da vida
então se sente muito mais acolhida e tem
menos stresse na vida Isso vai
proporcionar suporte emocional
suficiente reduzindo o risco de declínio
cognitivo então por exemplo você se
envolver em conversações que tenham o
significado para você que
temam um contexto assim edificante
participar de grupos atividades grupo
como eu comentei o night biker ou um
grupo de hobbies por exemplo observação
de pássaros né as pessoas adoram isso
daí você participar do grupo de
observação de aves é um grupo eh que tem
interesse em comum de Filosofia de artes
né E você alimentar esses
relacionamentos isso pode estimular o
seu cérebro né Isso vai promover
crescimento das conexões cerebrais e
melhorar a retenção de memória Então as
interações sociais são muito importantes
eh essa encorajamento de troca de ideias
saudáveis né Eh você se desafiar no
conhecimento no pensamento isso vai
ajudar demais e você manter a saúde
cerebral pessoas frequentemente se
aposentam e perdem essa característica
de buscar os desafios cerebrais não
querem aprender mais nada isso é um um
fato muito muito ruim que atrapalha
bastante essa pessoa que acaba tendo
esse DF cognitivo muito mais rápido tá
manter nossas mentes ativas
e atarefadas com coisas saudáveis é
muito importante tá Criar e
Man Criar e manter essa rede social eh
de suporte Pode parecer muito desafiador
Especialmente nos dias de hoje que é
muito corrido porém tem algum uns Passos
práticos que você pode fazer para
enriquecer a vida social Então comece
por exemplo eh tendo a iniciativa de
chegar perto dos seus amigos À vezes
você não conversa muito tempo e também
retomar contatos na sua família fazer um
esforço consciente para aumentar essa
conexão seja proativo proativa né
E
principalmente mente Mas se for
necessário use a tecnologia Mas faça
isso de uma maneira
eh pessoa a pessoa né cria essas
conexões de uma maneira mais intensa e
não fica só trocando mensagens
impessoais então tente eh se juntar a
clubes grupos de pessoas que têm
interesses em comum como eu já comentei
né Isso vai aumentar muito esse senso de
comunidade de satisfação com a vida né
também o voluntariado é uma coisa muito
poderosa se você tem tempo e já tem
recursos financeiros você não precisa
trabalhar para ter o seu sustento doe o
seu tempo para um asilo para uma casa de
repouso para um orfanato doi seu tempo
para as pessoas porque isso dá um um uma
uma sensação muito
poderosa para você de de tá sendo útil
pro próximo
né então como eu já comentei estimule o
seu cérebro né se comprometendo a um
conhecimento aprendizado para vida
inteira não aposente o seu cérebro Por
mais que você tenha tido uma vida
profissional muito ativa e você Quira
descansar eu acho que qualquer
aposentado depois de se meses já entra
numa pasmaceira Então procure comparecer
a workshops a cursos e cursos livres a
faculdade de terceiridade
isso é muito importante para você tá
sempre aprendendo e sempre estimulando o
seu cérebro isso também vai expandir o
seu ciclo social ao mesmo tempo que tá
estimulando o seu intelecto então esses
ambientes são Campos muito férteis para
discussão que podem melhorar as suas
funções cognitivas deixar você mais
afiado introduzir você a pessoas novas
que T outros backgrounds né Então essa
qualidade de interação social é tão
importante quanto a quantidade Então vai
buscar um contato ruim né uma pessoa que
vai te levar a sentimentos ruins pessoas
que têm más intenções ou pessoas que que
tão com maus hábitos de vida vai buscar
contatos que sejam edificantes né
conexões que tenham um significado que
vão proporcionar satisfação emocional
intelectual para
você isso vai ter um impacto muito
positivo na sua saúde
cognitiva vamos ver mais perguntas aqui
tentei dar óleo de coco mas parece que o
colesterol subiu HDL de 90 de 90 não é
ruim tá a não ser que tenha problema no
fígado tá trig de 70 tá
ótimo se você tem um HDL muito perto do
trigliceres esse LDL aí ele não é um LDL
inflamatório tá então HDL perto do
trigliceres quer dizer que o que o LDL
vamos lá HDL perto do trigliceres quer
dizer que o seu LDL colesterol é
saudável mesmo que ele esteja acima de
120 tá então isso daí eh Simone não
necessariamente é ruim tem que fazer a
relação entre Apô a1 e o Apô B fazer a
contra entre o apolipo proteína um Via B
E se tiver uma relação adequada entre um
o outro eu não me preocuparia tanto com
ridl o Eliseu tá comentando aqui que
Complexo B pode aumentar o apetite É
verdade olha aqui o a reg dizendo depois
que me aposentei fui aprender a tocar
violão para manter a memória ativa
parabéns pela sua
disposição faço alimentação saudável l
carb não como carboidratos refinados não
como farinha de trigo seus derivados
Parabéns
Má faço jejum intermitente minha mente
Clara areia fico com energia sobrando
para cuidar das crianças que bom muito
bom olha depoimento aqui da Marta estou
fazendo jejum de 12 a 15 horas
maravilhoso
parabéns pessoas negativas tô fora eu
também
M muito bom pessoal tem essa interação
de vocês
aqui vamos concluir
então
vamos concluir a nossa
Live
Ah tem uma coisa que eu não comentei em
relação à luz azul tá você vai trabalhar
à noite com o computador com celular
lembre-se uma hora antes de dormir para
com celular para com computador para com
tablet mas até essa hora de você
interromper o uso desses aparelhos uma
solução boa prática que eu não comentei
ainda é o uso de óculos bloqueadores de
luz azul esses óculos foram projetados
para filtrar a luz azul e permite que
nosso corpo se prepare para dormir
conforme a natureza pretendia né então
usos à noite especialmente nas últimas
horas antes de você dormir pode ajudar a
mitigar os efeitos da luz azul melhorar
a qualidade do sono então é hito simples
que pode ter um impacto significativo na
higiene do sono e na saúde
cognitiva se você mora num
lugar
que tem muita luz pela janela a você não
consegue deixar o quarto escuro Eu
graças a Deus eu consigo deixar o quarto
escuro uma opção é você usar cortinas
blackout para eliminar a poluição
Luminosa e manter uma temperatura
confortável então é interessante você
investir numa cortina blackout se você
não consegue deixar o quarto totalmente
escuro tente manter também uma
consistência no horário de sono dormindo
na mesma hora sempre mesmo horário e a
também eh no mesmo horário todos os
dias bem então estamos chegando ao final
dessa
Live ao encerrar a nossa
discussão vamos parar um momento para
refletir sobre que nós amos hoje aqui os
insites que nós
compartilhamos atravessamos o panorama
da Saúde cognitiva descobrimos a
importância das encores estilo de vida
na prevenção da perda de memória e da
demência falamos dos princípios da diet
ketoflex
123 dos benefícios restauradores do som
de qualidade também das técnicas de
relacionamento e meditação da redução do
estresse falamos do papel da vida social
é importante para nossa saúde
mental Falamos também do
jejum e falamos do estímulo cerebral
várias atividades diferentes lembre-se
que a jornada para manter a saúde do
cérebro é pessoal começa com passos
pequenos com passos consistentes e que
você vai agregando um ao outro
estabelece uma mudança de estilo de vida
um hábito
eh fortalece esse hábito agrega outro
fortalece agrega outro então incorpore
mais alimentos naturais tire os
alimentos que você tem desembrulhar da
sua dieta e coloque os alimentos que
você tem descascar dedique tempo a sua
atividade física melhore a seu ingi do
Sono melhore o seu gerenciamento do
estresse adotando prática de redução
desse estresse com meditação oração
mindfulness e também as técnicas de
relaxamento na natureza como eu comentei
o também o a questão do grounding né do
aterramento você ter o pé na areia o pé
na grama o pé na natureza para você
trocar solo né cada uma dessas ações um
passo em direção à longevidade
cognitiva não esqueçamos o profundo
Impacto também do envolvimento social do
nosso bem-estar mental construir e
nutrir uma rede de apoio de amigos e
familiares tem um papel fundamental
criar essa comunidade esse senso de
comunidade pode proporcionar não só o
companheirismo mas também um escudo
protetor contra o declínio cognitivo
então agora é a sua vez de levar essas
estratégias de de conceito nós estamos
falando aqui paraa sua prática comece
avaliando o seu estilo de vida atual
identificando áreas que você pode
implementar essas mudanças vai fazendo
uma co de cada vez pequenos
para você atingir um grande objetivo lá
na frente trata-se de progresso não de
perfeição toda mudança positiva é uma
vitória para sua saúde cognitiva eu
convido vocês a compartilhar suas
experiências e dúvidas tá vamos vamos
responder aqui às últimas perguntas que
vocês estão colocando
aqui vamos promover uma comunidade onde
possamos apoiar inspirar uns aos outros
na jornada vão no canal Procure os
vídeos antigos sobre dieta que eu falo
com detalhe sobre a dieta cetogênica
Procure os vídeos que eu falo sobre o
protocolo recod tá e se você encontrou
valor na nossa conversa de hoje não tá
inscrito ainda se inscreva no nosso
canal considere se inscrever para obter
mais
conteúdo que vai levar você a uma vida
mais saudável e cognitivamente vibrante
Compartilha essa transmissão ao vivo com
seus amigos e familiares que também pode
beneficiar ess estratégias para melhorar
a vida então juntos vamos espalhar a
informação do bem a mensagem que vai
ajudar você evitar uma doença
tão Implacável quanto a demência tá
entendamos que o declínio cognitivo não
é uma parte inevitável do envelhecimento
e que as nossas escolhas T um papel
muito importante no modo de moldar o
destino do nosso cérebro vamos ver as
últimas perguntas para gente poder
encerrar
aqui
Obrigado pelo teu
comentário é um prazer terla aqui
conosco aqui na nossa Live Obrigado
mesmo pelo
comentário como que um Gama GT de 35 e
um
de deve ter tido um errinho aí tão de
32 dessa TGO né pode ter relação com
Alzheimer não tem relação direta Mas se
você tiver uma função do fígado ruim Com
certeza você vai impactar sua saúde
cerebral tem vídeo no canal falando
sobre a saúde do fígado e a sua relação
com o cérebro dá uma olhada depois
ah nairo eh fale sobre suplementos Tá eu
vou abrir aqui um documento que fala dos
principais suplementos tá vou mostrar
para vocês aqui na
tela
bem vou abrir
aqui bem vou mostrar aqui rapidamente
suplementos para vocês não era o
objetivo dessa Live né para mais estilo
de
vida
eh deixa eu ver se eu eu tir me tirando
da
tela vamos deixar
assim bem deixa eu apliar a tela aqui
na se ampliar demais vai
ficar ruim eu acho vamos
ver
tá Esses são os
principais nutrientes el carnitina vai
aumentar beta oxidação de gorduras no
cérebro Então vai ajudar queimar as
gorduras
a acetic colina ela é uma substância
também que vai ser incorporada na parede
nos neurônios e vai
ajudar também na
comunicação celular
né do neurônio com meio externo a com
enzima q10 com pqq v melhorar a função
mitocondrial que vai ter efeito
antioxidante o magnésio também na forma
de at vai passar a barreira
hematoencefálica e vai ter uma ação
muito interessante na promoção da Saúde
cerebral até porque ele também é um
calmante tiamina que é a
vitamina
B1 ela tem um efeito também de baixar o
açúcar do sangue melhorar o metabolismo
cerebral o Resveratrol efeito
antioxidante a vitamina B12 é muito
importante pro metabolismo cerebral a
vitamina D3 H2 o ômega-3 tá Esses são os
principais tá tem muito mais do que isso
tá muito mais do que isso eu só tô dando
aqui um uma
pincelada dos
principais última pergunta que eu vou
responder hoje Doutor
picnogenol
e bacopa monieri pode ser tomado juntos
para a memória Sim Podem o piquin genal
é muito bom paraa saúde das artérias do
cérebro bacon aenta o bdnf e o
ngf são fatores de crescimento cerebral
tá então vai ajudar pessoal muito
obrigado pelo tempo que
vocês despenderam aqui para participar
dessa Live
de coração agradeço a vocês e nós nos
vemos nas próximas lives um grande
abraço beijo no coração de vocês vocês
são
Vera